I think the Internet is can be very
useful I mean people have websites in
fact I have a website and I'm 59 years
old that must be really stupid it's it's
a huge you know important innovation but
does it have anything to do with what I
do I mean meet Julian Schnabel not
really I'm more like a cave person I'm
actually painting something with my own
hands doesn't go through the airwaves in
invisible speed and end up in somebody's
head it's about you're looking at
something and you're finding something
that's inside of yourself the internet
helps with education making people more
aware of certain things but really you
think you can get anything on the
internet I could think of something that
I could say right now that you couldn't
get on the Internet I'd like to have a
plastic awning from a butcher shop in
the Atlas Mountains in Morocco when it's
rolled up it's red but where it's been
exposed to cover the window of the
butcher shop
the Sun I'd like this the Sun needs to
bleach it
so it's ochre it's kind of an ochre and
dirt color and the image of that will
look like the New York skyline I think
it'd be very hard to order one of those
it's those are the kinds of things you
have to go there see them find them and
then get 10 guys to help you disengage
it from the metal structure that's
hanging over that butcher shop and your
kids have to watch well it's very boring
and it's hot out there as the people
fold it up and it smells like meat but
you stick it in your suitcase and maybe
if you get it back to New York stick it
on a stretcher and make a painting of it
put some white on it write a word on it
and then you've got your art and then
somebody can look at it and see if it
means anything to them you look at
what's not generic you look at something
that becomes a
palimpsest some kind of stasis that can
include things that are nameable and
unnameable and these unnameable things
that i mentioned before the things that
I try to put in or that I put into the
movies
that's like silence you sense it
sometimes and you think I feel more
alive so as an artist what do I really
do I point and say did you see that
can you see that